Clayton wants to know how do you push
your team beyond their best clicking
great question way to start off 2015
good questions Oh actually I picked this
one right like who doesn't Barry
Horowitz's but I was so subconscious -
there's a good question I thought we
should do it um I really really really
think that the best way to push somebody
above their own means is to guilt them
into it and I know that's a weird kind
of answer but it is my honest belief
that the thing that drive first of all
everybody's driven by different things
so the real answer to your question is
to use your ear right
d-roc zoom in to my ear right you know
the ear is the key in this scenario
because the truth is the way to push
somebody above their limits is to
actually have individual conversations
with them about what is their holy you
know Grail right like what do they want
to accomplish like Indy and I I like I
have a good feel of some of India's
long-term career ambitions and like that
gives me first of all her knowing that
we've even had that conversation in in
itself gives her a little bit more
confidence to work harder because she's
trying to get what she wants out of it
professionally and knowing that I'm the
person that could most likely make that
happen at least in the context of this
world that just even having the
conversation puts her in a better spot
that some people are literally Rolly
driven by straight cash but truly like
like you want to push somebody like you
carrot like hey I know you love cash
I'll give you ten thousand more if you
like you know like and so you've got to
find out what makes people tick
I'm so not motivated by cash that so
many people try to get me to do things
JV with me invest in things do things
speak at things because they and they
think cash is the way of doing listen I
love the cash but is not my biggest
driver and I make a lot of decisions
based on legacy long-term impact on
myself by the way not like long-term
global impact you know you know that's
not not how I think I mean I think
there's a byproduct of that but it's not
number one thing for me but to answer
the question in a general form I truly
do believe the best way to get that is
to guilt and what I mean by guilt it's a
variation of listening which is not only
listening but delivering in a world
where so few people even begin to listen
let alone delivering on that listening
and once you start doing that people
start realizing let me tell you what's
happening at Vayner it's not super
confusing I know exactly what's going on
in this company it's starting to get old
enough that there's enough things
happening for enough people that it's
really easy to point to Phil Toronto or
just somebody else and be like wait a
minute
we're Steve Unwin like you can start
pointing to oh crap that person wanted
that that person's getting that that
person's happiest crap I want that and
so it's listening and then delivering
which then creates a scenario where
people want to over deliver because the
only way somebody will over deliver for
you because you ask the very selfish
question how can I get my team to over
deliver for me for my thing it's very
simple the best way to get them to over
deliver John yeah that's know jack is
not a substitute I know where you're
thinking but like no that's not a
substitute we run and uh you know the
only way to get somebody to over deliver
is to attack their own selfishness
there's your selfish because you want
more out of your team to help you well
the best way to get that to happen is to
over-deliver against their selfishness I
do believe that guilt is a huge driver
because there's something that I believe
in human beings I mean some people don't
have self-awareness or empathy or these
emotional feelings but so many people
like it's amazing to me now living 20
years professionally like how many
people are not confused eventually they
may be emotional at the time you fire
them or not reward them but boy every
time I run into somebody four seven nine
years down the line I've had a very good
track record of them saying yeah I know
why you did that or I mean like crazy
stuff like I had a drug problem like
there's like you know stuff life right
so I would answer your question uh like
I have before on this show and if you
haven't heard me
say it I'll say it again the single best
way to win is to give 51% of the
relationship if there was a jury of 500
people that they would all agree that
you've given 51% to the relationship and
you have to be good enough to know what
to do with the other 49 so I would
attack their own selfishness I would
make it so good for them that you've
guilted them in delivering and be very
prepared in your stomach by making it
awesome and them under-delivering still
being entitled to think they did deliver
and then you being disappointed you
listen to the garyvee show and he told
you and he's so great at least you think
so thank you very much and you did it
and in all four of these people you gave
$10,000 raises to yesterday a month
later are doing the same crap they did
and it didn't move ate them at all or
you gave them four weeks off instead of
one week off and they're still just as
crappy or you like that them a
babysitter you pay for it and they still
aren't gratitude and all these wonderful
human characteristics are not guaranteed
but the best way for you to have it
happen is to consistently keep trying to
do it for that person and then look I
just had a meeting with all these
characters right and but the rest of the
team and I was like look like you may
not win on this team like 2015 I want to
take it up another notch and the
consolation prize is you get to work for
one of the best companies in the world
but like you just might not be able to
be on this team like you've got to be up
front
you've got to be fair you got to know
when you're setting up people for
victory and when not you got to do that
and then you get the judge not
beforehand way too many of you are
making a mistake yourself you didn't
train you didn't put the person in
position to succeed you're not
communicating properly on what you
expect you're not shooting it straight
you're scared hard feelings you're too
much of a dick it could be a million
different reasons why it's not happening
but it is always going to be the
greatest form of meritocracy that you
can create and that starts with your ear
and it ended and it finishes in my
opinion on a second step move of you
actually delivering on that call
people's Bluffs I live life on calling
people's Bluffs oh you'll really crush
it if you have another person here now
you have to be good enough back that 49%
to afford to give somebody that person
right you may not have that situation
right you might have to make a decision
one of the quickest ways I grew Wine
Library was by making thirty thousand
dollars a year for five years in a row
because I took all those monies and I
called people's Bluffs and when they let
me down do you think it hurt my feelings
that I wasn't making 45 instead of 30 it
sure did but then I have my eye on the
big prize
sure did now I get to pay double that
salary to speak for one hour because I
felt long-term because I was 23 years
old
right you got to know where you're at if
you're 83 and you're watching the show
first of all Big Ups old dog and second
of all second of all you know maybe you
don't need to play the long game and
invest as much maybe it's time to cash
out I'm these weird feelings that in my
80s I'm gonna be rogas crap and just
like take because I just gave for so
long I don't know you've heard me say
that that's my concern but I can tell
you this
most of the reasons let me rephrase if
they work for you all of the reasons
that they're not over delivering against
their best all of those reasons are your
fault oh crap wait subscribe do I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe